je vous en parlais il ya quelques jours
j'ai reçu une énorme valise c'est ce
truc là c'est la valise qui contient le
rock phone est plein d'accessoires de
rhésus dédiés aux gamers
alors ce qu'on va faire or le faire en
plusieurs temps tout de suite on nous la
valise en gare quatre dents ont fait un
dock singh très très très rapide jouve
le smartphone jeu break je coupe vous me
laissez plusieurs jours pour moi ça va
durer plusieurs jours pour vous en a
duré le temps d'un claquement de doigts
je reviens et ensuite je vous explique
ce que je pense de 2 sur iphone et on
aime en faire deux vidéos d'une première
vidéo pour vraiment parler du rock folk
une deuxième vidéo pour parler des
accessoires et l'expérience de jeu à mon
avis ça va être complètement dingue
[Musique]
c'est énorme
autiste valises on va s'ouvrir ce truc
est juste officines republic of gamers
c'est dur shaw coup de pression de ouf
display doc mobile destock doctrine view
doc
qu'est ce que c'est que ça la drogue
aérodium système c'est quoi ce truc je
ne sais absolument pas professional doc
qu'elle valse rock folk et franchement
c'est juste ou fille sim
il est là le rock phone c'est absolument
énorme genève une boîte de smartphones
comme ça alors là on est vraiment dans
des codes très particulier le packaging
est juste à lui sinon à l'ouverture sous
forme de voler comme ça ça claque
complet alors le smartphone est juste là
ça c'est vous aussi massif ça c'est
franchement une belle date il fait ses
200 g il a un design d'ailleurs qui est
complètement atypique pour les gaming
là on le voit c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment magnifique charger ou
même le câble de recharge regarder ça la
qualité des matériaux est vraiment
vraiment vraiment classe on à de l'usb
type c'est un héros active couleur donc
ça c'est pour le refroidissement il
vient se mettre comme ça et vous avez
quand même si votre prise en usb tilt
c'est votre prise jack qui est
complètement préservé son côté on va
retrouver ici
bouton de volume bouton pour l'allumer
en dessous prise jack 3.5 ici l'usb type
c ici vous avez le port alors je connais
pas le nom du porte ça vous sert à
relayer l'usb type c est la prise jack
ici vous avez votre tiroir de cartes sim
double nano sim à l'intérieur sur le
dessus rien à l'arrière double module
photo 12 + 5 ici
une prise d'air pour le refroidissement
on a eu notre caméra à l'avant ici on a
deux haut parleurs en a un là haut
parleurs stéréo le public aux bouches
on a une vraie sensation de puissance et
là franchement je viens plein de
l'allumer j'ai mis le wifi je télécharge
deux trois trucs et c'est vrai que ça
réagit tout de suite c'est hyper hyper
impressionnant
la rapidité du truc c'est juste ou
fissiles j'ai vraiment hâte donc là je
vais le tester
laissez-moi quelques jours le temps d'un
claquement de doigts et je reviens
juste waouh ça fait quelques jours
maintenant que j'utilise le rock funk
d'asus et je suis franchement hyper
hyper hyper épaté hyper hyper bluffé
alors il ya des choses que j'aime bien
de même un petit peu moins mais je suis
franchement épaté par cette bécane
pascal et qualité complètement
hallucinante c'est un smartphone de
grippe
c'est un smartphone de google c'est un
smartphone de guémy je vous explique
j'ai une question pour vous qu'est ce
qui fait qu'un smartphone de gaming est
un smartphone de gaming vous avez cinq
secondes 1 2 3 4 5 vous m'avez écrit en
commentaire
c'est pas le cam était la pause pub
allez on y va qu'est ce qui fait qu'un
smartphone de gaming est un smartphone
de gaming c'est pas du tout du look
extravagant des smartphones de guémy
hyper rasées c'est un ensemble de son
espèce de produits qui est complètement
cohérent plus de ça il faut beaucoup de
performances ça c'est le premier point
ces points essentiels
là vous avez beaucoup de performances
snapdragon glissant 45 overclockée jusqu
à 2,96 gigas 8 gigas de ram
lp ddr4 x ça marche très très bien ça
marche du feu de dieu
et lorsque vous le pousse à fond la même
tendance un petit peu chauffé écoutez
pas lui en vouloir au point de vue
graphique point de vue gpu vous avez une
adreno 630 ça marche super bien on nous
annonce un temps de réponse inférieur à
1 milliseconde franchement je saurai pas
de quantifier le mesurer mais ce que je
sais vrai nom vous dire c'est que la
sensation à l'ouverture d'une
application à la faveur d'une
application vous sentez même pas vous
toucher appel par ces faits didier
gonzales très bizarre très compliqué à
transmettre de cette manière là mais des
smartphones cuisson jantes est très
souvent destin dragon 845 j'en ai testé
un paquet je sais très bien comment ça
marche des smartphones avec 8 gigas de
ram a déjà testé des smartphones de
gaming déjà testé ces pas dire que celui
là est au dessus de tous les smartphones
de gaming
mais seule une est en tout cas c'est en
vrai bon smartphone de gaming il est
hyper puissant hyper performant en plus
au niveau de l'affichage vous avez un
taux de rafraîchissement de 90 heures
c'est pas ça vous parle alors le
razer phone aller un peu plus haut avec
120 heures 90' c'est déjà ça donne
quelque chose d'hyper fluide c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment hyper cool
comme tout bon smartphone de gaming il a
un loup qui complètement rasées vous
avez une surcouche qui est franchement
bien c'est la rogue gaming ça c'est la
surcouche de asus il tourne sur un
android et 8.1 oreo j'adore cette
surcouche alors on est vraiment dans
l'école du gaming vous le voyez là
typiquement avec ses zicos vous avez
tout l'univers qui est là c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment magnifique et regardez
je sais pas si on se rencontre comme ça
mais ça va hyper hyper super hyper vite
c'est franchement hyper hyper hyper
hyper hyper agréable
vous avez ici des doubles haut parleurs
stéréo si vous montrez dans quelques
instants lorsque vous jouez c'est un
truc qui est complètement ouf parce que
lorsque vous prenez votre smartphone
mais lorsque vous jouez vous avez
vraiment une sensation d'immersion sans
vraiment en sont très claires c'est un
son qui est vraiment très très limpide
qui vient de chaque côté sage et vous le
montrez ce rendez vous le montre aussi
en vidéo vous allez voir cette hyper
hyper hyper cool c'est un écran amoled
diagonale 6 pouces avec une résolution
de 2160 par 1080 pixels format 18
deviennent luminosité de 500 dit bon
c'est très lumineux je suis pas aller
jouer dehors en place way parce qu'on
est au mois de décembre il n'y a pas
plein de soleil mais en tout cas pour
jouer long des différentes conditions
j'ai pu le faire c'est franchement cool
corning gorilla glass pour le protéger
ils filtrent les lumières bleues ça
c'est cool
vous pouvez faire des jeux en hdr vous
avez vraiment une qualité qui
complètement hallucinante
[Musique]
bon alors droit aux parieurs gauche est
vrai vous lèverez révèle satellisation
du ce ont beaucoup de puissance
un son qui est un peu les dionne
forcément a fallu en vouloir on n'a pas
les seules ou faire là dessus par contre
ça marche très très bien
c'est vraiment génial parce que quand on
joue en face je vous le dis on a
vraiment la sensation que son vient de
chaque côté c'est pas un petit haut
parleur qui va être coincé ici à dans
une grille en dessous c'est vraiment des
haut-parleurs en façade
ça donne un look un peu particulier par
contre l'expérience le niveau du son et
au niveau notamment du gaming c'est
franchement génialissime genève ce sera
compliqué de se rendre compte comme ça
je croyais et moyens volumes ici dans la
pièce l'a rarement jamais eu directement
avec un smartphone c'est juste
hallucinant la vitesse des truffes
le son crash ça va hyper hyper hyper
super hyper hyper dit également éviter
absolue c'est franchement franchement
génial typiquement s'écoulait qu'un jeu
comme pib j'essaie vraiment de fusil t
de la puissance alors celui au final
vous pouvez jouer avec beaucoup beaucoup
moins de puissance mais à quinta
dragonne 660 ça marchera parfaitement
bien vous sentez pas mêmes qualités
graphiques mais ça marchera par contre
ce qui est sûr c'est que pdg avec un
smartphone comme ça c'est complètement
complètement complètement sûr optimiser
sa marche du feu de dieu c'est
franchement franchement une expérience
qui est vraiment génial donc on
expérience de jeu vous avez quelque
chose qui est complètement complètement
complètement optimisé je vais vous
mettre droit serré mais comme ça ouais
ça va mieux comme ça c'est hyper hyper
optimisé en plus vous avez un retour
haptique ce qui fait que lorsque on dit
par exemple à des jeux de shoot vous
sentez howe est ce qu on vous tire vous
le voyez vraiment donc ça c'est vraiment
hyper hyper intuitif et c'est tout
l'intérêt d'un smartphone de gaming
c'est ce qui fait l'adn d'un smartphone
de gainey par rapport à un smartphone
classique avec des spect sensiblement
similaire au delà du côté overclockée
vraiment le danger encore plus de
puissance
tu as forcément besoin pour les jeux
actuels mais par contre vous avez tout
un écosystème complet je vous parle même
pas les accessoires sont apparaît dans
une prochaine vidéo je vous parle
vraiment de se dire que c'est hyper
optimiser le son est optimisé la crèche
et optimiser le retour haptique avec des
vibrations qui est complètement utilisé
un dos reis qui complètement optimisé
vous l'avez même en
direct là au milieu vous appuyez dessus
vous avez votre centre de jeu qui vous
indique la température de votre cpu la
fréquence utilisée la mémoire utilisée
le gpu la température pareil la
fréquence utilisée le stockage utilisé
soit vous êtes en odyx soit vous êtes
sans me disent ça c'est à vous de
choisir vous mêmes un profil de ce que
vous pouvez paramétrer pouvez paramétrer
pour chaque jeu je vous prends par
exemple le bvg 'mobile' vous pouvez
nettoyer mémoire peut choisir la
fréquence maximum du cpu sont tous des
petits détails mais qui font franchement
la différence par rapport aux autres
smartphones
le taux de rafraîchissement comme
système 60 hertz 90 hier si vous faites
comme vous voulez c'est toutes ces
petites options qui font de ce
smartphone un excellent smartphone pour
les gamers
lorsque vous branchez l'accessoire en
plus qui fourni dans la boîte d'origine
d'un petit ventilateur qui vaille dalle
ventilé vous pouvez venir ici dans votre
centre de jeu régler la vitesse du
ventilateur soit en automatique soit
vous pouvez régler directement faible
élevé bon par contre là vous allez voir
ou d'un moment ça fait un petit peu de
bruit peut même venir régler votre
éclairage aura l'éclairage aura vous
l'avez ici mais vous l'avez aussi au dos
du smartphone vous l'avez eue si votre
éclairage vous pouvez venir le
paramétrer sans aucun problème soit vous
laissez un cycle de couleur avec des
couleurs aléatoire statique respiration
stroboscopique cycle de couleur vous
faites comme vous voulez vous pouvez
régler la luminosité pouvez régler le
débit pourrait faire comme vous
souhaitez sa femme est complètement
personnalisation smartphones et même de
le lier à des équipes l'équipe qui
pourrait avoir une telle couleur l'autre
équipe de deux couleurs enfin voilà ça
permet encore d'aller plus loin au
niveau de l'univers du gaming
vous pouvez par exemple synchronisée
l'éclairage avec un groupe ou carrément
rejoindre un groupe et vous avez même
les paramètres génie du jeu dans lequel
vous allez pouvoir paramétrer pas mal de
choses
la barre d'outils de jeu définissez
votre image de profiter pas mal de
possibilités rejet automatique des
appels si vous ne pas être dérangé les
différents paramètres lorsque vous êtes
filmé la résolution de la vidéo de la
microphone vous connecter à votre compte
twitter contre youtube
la résolution de la diffusion en direct
lorsque vous stream et la source
le microphone interne voire pourquoi pas
carrément un microphone externe et vous
avez également le earth rigueur le r
trigger va se déclencher lorsque vous
allez serré d'un côté ou de l'autre
vous pouvez venir le paramétrer et
lorsque vous jouez ça va aussi pouvoir
vous servir de petits
gachet virtuel et si au milieu tout ça
que vous sentez un peu largué vous allez
y si vous allez dans faq vous avez plein
de questions et vous aurez plein de
réponses autre point essentiel d'un
assaut smartphone au côté gamer très
très prononcé c'est son look
vous avez un look franchement
franchement connoté des moeurs vous avez
les grilles de ventilation ici pour
venir à aider votre smartphone à
respirer même la découpe au niveau du
module photo à une forme gamer pour
trouver tous et ça c'est vraiment un
smartphone dont l'adn est gay mis ça
quand on le voit il ne transpire de tous
les côtés un smartphone avec un cpu
overclockée c'est un smartphone qui
forcément va chauffer et c'est là où
aussi à vue soit vraiment loin dans le
côté gaming si vous avez un
refroidissement à chambre à vapeur vous
avez ici là à sortir un petit peu l'air
chaud on va pas se mentir lorsque vous
pouvez sur des grosses sessions gaming
il va chauffer je vous conseille quand
même de mettre sous tutelle c'est ce
soir que vous avez intérieur qui va
ventilé l'air de toute façon ça chauffe
ça chauffe
on joue on joue c'est comme ça en
attendant c'est bien qu'asus et apporter
des solutions concrètes pour éviter que
votre machine vous brûle le bout des
doigts
après le passé surtout benchmark il a un
score de 300 en 1636 selon les résultats
dans tout où il est classé numéro deux
juste après le mec 20 projets le mail en
pro à à la note 2 309 1628 surtout celui
ci sur auto a été classé à 281 7000 à 60
18 mois selon vos résultats vous bien il
est encore plus performant il va encore
plus vite donc c'est toujours à pas
grand chose
et derrière on a le one + 6 qui est 280
points 0,07 donc en tout cas cette
machine au terme de performance elle est
à lui si nantes
bon mais tout ça soulève aussi des
questions celle de l'autonomie
vous avez une batterie de 4000 millions
terreur à l'intérieur ça fonctionne mais
lorsque vous faites tourner la machine à
fond les ballons avec un ventilateur
arrière
dites vous bien que votre autonomie elle
doit diminuer assez rapidement ça c'est
normal
si vous êtes en récession un petit peu
de jeu un peu plus hardcore fait par son
chargeur histoire de lui mettre un petit
coup de recharge après rassurez-vous le
dessus vous avez de la recharge rapide
recharge 30 watts
ça va suffisamment vite c'est de l'usb
type c c'est cool ça recharge 8 du monde
vous faites des grandes sessions de jeu
vous allez consommer mais par contre
vous rechargez derrière ça va vite c'est
cool lorsque vous jouez par exemple ici
à 7,9
c'est pas obligé de vous dire si fortes
ont dénoncé peu une fréquence maximum de
deux points 96 guerre vous pouvez vous
dire je veux faire tourner un peu moins
est ce que john nécessite cette
fréquence là j'en suis pas persuadé de
la même manière pour rafraîchissement
est ce que vous devez avoir un
rafraîchissement à 90 ans pour tous les
jeux je ne suis pas sûr non plus qu'il
ya pas mal de petits réglages vous
permettront d'optimiser la durée de vie
de votre batterie
ça c'est cool vous avez le asus noise
rejection joli accent je sais en gros
vous avez trois micro externe qui vont
servir réduire le bruit ambiant lorsque
vous allez passer des coups de fil et en
plus de ça vous avez du nfc du bluetooth
5.0 vous avez deux cartes sim à
l'intérieur voilà ça c'est assez complet
maintenant je pose une question c'est
qu'en est il quand même de la photo
vidéo c'est un smartphone de gaming va
pas faire le focus sur la photo vidéo au
dessus mais on va quand même faire
quelques photos il faire une petite
vidéo histoire de voir si ce point là
aussi est à la hauteur oui ou non vous
avez un double module à l'arrière en
premier capteur sony mx360 3 12
mégapixels la taille de pixel fait 1,4
micromètres l ouverture de f
1.7 ça c'est le meilleur des deux il a
un autofocus à détection de phase enfin
il marche très bien stabilisation
optique sur quatre axes tout ça couplet
de la stabilisation électronique ça
marche c'est bien deuxième caméra 8
mégapixels grand-angle 120° vous allez
voir c'est un peu moins bien ça marche
vraiment bien que vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de lumière
extérieure pourrait filmer
je tends 4k uhd à 60 images par seconde
mais aussi faire du slow motion à 240
images par seconde en 1080 halte et ça
c'est pour l'arrière à l'avant vous avez
une caméra ici une caméra de 8
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.0 à
la petite est vidée
pour me dire ce que vous en pensez bon
le rendu franchement cool après on sait
très bien que asus maîtrise franchement
la partie photo vidéo je vous ai fait un
test notamment du asus iphone 5
z qui fonctionne super bien ça c'est la
caméra arrière et on va faire un tour du
côté de la caméra avant et voilà bon
alors pas trop mal se passer
bon à la cause de ce que je vous disais
moi je pense que de ce côté-là ça
fonctionne c'est pas non plus un
photophone c'est pas un truc
complètement hallucinant néanmoins on
est sur une machine qui est franchement
hyper cool et qui est très bien placée
en termes de tarifs mais ça je vous en
parle juste après vous avoir montré
quelques photos puis vous montrer ce
qu'on peut faire en termes de prise de
vue là dessus toi de portrait moi je
trouve extrêmement bien réussit ça
fonctionne du feu de dieu le détourage
et franchement franchement franchement
tope là vous voyez ici entre les doigts
vous n'avez absolument aucune erreur le
détourage est quasiment parfait
c'est franchement franchement bien là
même lorsqu'on va complexifier la selle
c'est pareil entre les doigts ça marche
bien c'est cool là le détourage vers le
pouce marche très très bien s toute la
puissance industrielle 1945
là vous avez une photo pour normal là
vous l'avez avec le grand-angle bon on a
un peu plus de mal le point vraiment
fait sur la feuille
grâce à l'autofocus à détection de phase
de là tout est dit vous n'allez pas en
plus grand temps que ça marche tout de
suite beaucoup moins bien pareil sans
grand temps qu'on a assez de détails ça
marche bien avec le grand-angle pour
perdu détail tout beaucoup plus
brouillon pas grand angle plus grand
angle pas grand-angle grand-angle pas
grand-angle grand temps voilà c'est tout
de suite beaucoup beaucoup moins bien
vous
sans grand temps que par contre vous
avez un vrai beau détails mais lorsque
vous allez venir
zoom est dedans je trouve que l'appareil
photo là dessus est franchement
franchement très très bon enfin cette
photo est prise avec est la caméra de
celle fille c'est pareil ça marche
franchement bien là on est sur des
conditions de faible luminosité sur
l'appareil 2 mégapixels ouverture de f
1.7 bon ça fonctionne il n'y a vraiment
pas beaucoup de lumière dans le vide au
moment où je fais cette photo là ça
fonctionne
là on passe sur le grand temps il ya un
peu plus de bruit sur le visage à vous
le voyez pas son visage sur la figurine
en tout cas il est beaucoup plus de
bruit tandis que de l'autre côté vous en
avez quand même beaucoup moins ça marche
beaucoup mieux sorte phone n'est pas du
tout un smartphone qui est fait pour la
partie photo vidéo qui en tout cas a été
créé pour la partie photo vidéo
néanmoins il peut s'appuyer sur des
connaissances solides et une belle
maîtrise de la part d'asus
il ya une vraie belle maîtrise logiciel
une vraie belle maîtrise hardware
également aussi là dessus alors si vous
voulez acheter un smartphone de gaming
sur la partie photo vidéo vous serez pas
déçus surtout sur la partie photo avec
capteur de 12 mégapixels avec autofocus
à détection de phase celui là c'est le
principal sens celui là qu'il faut
stable et le grand temps de jeu 10 ans
conditions de pleine luminosité en
extérieur lorsqu'il fait beau ça
marchera après c'est pas non plus tu es
mieux qu'en est il maintenant du tarif
parce que là je parle de plein de choses
nous parle du smartphone si et ça voilà
même tarif au final
franchement ils écoulent 899 euros pour
la puissance que vous avez derrière pour
l'optimisation 899 euros pour un
smartphone de gaming
moi je trouve ça franchement franchement
hyper cool et ça me pose absolument
aucun problème je vais pas dire non plus
que 899 euros ce n'est pas d'argent
c'est beaucoup d'argent mais pour avoir
un smartphone de cette qualité en termes
de performance je trouve ça franchement
cool on pourrait avoir à tarif
équivalent des smartphones bien
meilleure en termes de photos mais là
c'est pas l'adn de ce produit je le
trouve bien il est performant il est
cool et je trouve qu asus a vraiment
fait un excellent produit avec se
rendent folle je sais pas vous ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes gamers c'est le cas
dit moi tout en bas en commentaire est
ce que vous le trouvez bien ce rock funk
d'asus est ce que vous l'avez essayé ce
que vous l'avez acheté est ce que vous
trouvez que aziz
vraiment dans le bon sens avec ce
smartphone par extension est ce que vous
aimez les pc asus est ce que vous aimez
les ordis de gaming asus vous marquez
tout ça ça ouvre un people à la
discussion en temps dans la moi je vous
dis je trouve cool dit si tu es toujours
on va se voir la vidéo complète de tous
les accessoires avec son beau sur sous
blister
et croyez moi allez voir aussi plein de
choses à dire là on va plus parler à
d'expérience de jeu de possibilités
d'eco systèmes complets et ça aussi
c'est un des points très très fort ce
produit ça va forcément augmenter l
addition mais par contre vous allez
pouvoir aller beaucoup plus loin
avoir une manette le mettre sur son
écran de télé un truc complètement
hallucinant mais ça je vous en parle
d'ici quelques jours je vous invite
également à les consulter ma playlist
pour découvrir tous les smartphones du
moment vous faire votre avis quelle tout
ça tout ça voilà je vous embrasse son
message et à très bientôt
ciao